One of the things that's extraordinary
about our executive education offerings is
that the Stanford Graduate School of
Business is of course located in the heart
of Stanford University, which in turn is
located in the heart of Silicon Valley.
So this is a center of innovation.
It's at the cutting edge of technology.
This is where many of the brand name
startups in the world have been founded.
And executive education programs give
our participants the opportunity
to come to Stanford, or to come and
join us if we're abroad in their location.
And understand what some of these
cutting edge, innovative ideas are, and
how they can take those ideas and
really propel their organizations forward.
>> We're able to draw on all
the schools in the university, and
bring together experts from each of these
areas that can help us understand and
focus on the business problems of today.
Our faculty here are an outstanding set
of social scientists who observe and
analyze the business world.
And who are able to distill what
they learn from their observations
into actionable managerial plans and
frameworks.
>> The cornerstone of our campus reads,
dedicated to the things that
haven't happened yet and
the people who will dream them up.
And I think that in a nutshell
captures the essence of the GSB.